[Music]
was our first feature a point break did
we do that before
not officially yeah right so as a
company tremors would be the first
technically the first feature i guess i
don't know
someone should google that
[Music]
are you going to ask us questions or do
you want us to start talking could you
introduce each other i would love to i
would like to introduce you to tom
woodruff jr who is the co-founder of
amalgamated dynamics i'd like to
introduce you to alec gillis he's the
co-founder of adi home of the
oscar-winning creature effects team
when people think of practical effects
creatures you think of non-computer
generated characters we've been lucky to
be involved with some of the biggest and
best of those types of monsters we did
the worms and tremors we did the fat
makeups on tim allen in the santa claus
all the practical animals in jumanji
we've done the alien we've done the
predator starship troopers i wasn't done
you can keep going buddy and of course
there's always the gorilla
cut right now that's perfect right now
we cut putting the gorilla costume
[Music]
we started performing our own creatures
because we both had this sort of
observation of stuntmen despite their
talents and their skills them going into
a creature suit and not really knowing
how to make a creature suit work
it would be very weird for us to just
say we're going to build something and
then bring it to set and say now what
are you hungry
you want some food are you hungry if
you're a digital animator you build the
character and you follow through and you
make it move and you bring it to life so
that's our philosophy is the final step
is performance because that's where it
lives
you want to try a little tiny piece here
go ahead go ahead
what do you think you want some more you
hey hey he's
listen
listen i can get you fresh bread i can i
can get you fresh bread
tremors is an example of a film that was
from the pre-digital era and if you look
at it the practical effects they've
stood the test of time and we're proud
of that
digital effects can do things that we
can't possibly do practical effects have
a presence to them that even the best
cgi work gets close to but doesn't
completely achieve
in other words there's more emotion i
believe to a practical creature than to
a digital creature wave to the camera
and say goodbye
bye bye
bye
[Music]
[Music]
for 31 years i have been acting in
major motion pictures and tv series but
you
may not recognize my face
i'm doug jones i am an actor
[Music]
i got into acting out of a
need almost to
be validated and it was at ball state
university that i discovered the art of
mime it's a very visual form of
communication and entertainment
little did i know that this would be
early training ground for the career
that i was going to have late in later
years i had no idea
after moving out to hollywoodland in
march of 1985
and thinking okay now is the time to
pursue this acting thing my fourth
booking
was for a mcdonald's campaign that got
me kind of hooked into oh he's that tall
skinny guy who wears stuff and
moves well in it and doesn't complain
while doing so
my first feature film was batman returns
i got that audition because of my
contorted legs in the credits it says
thin clown which kind of
it's kind of self-descriptive isn't it i
have been in over 150 productions that
would include everything from feature
films like hocus pocus hellboy 1 hellboy
2 the golden army the fawn in pans
labyrinth was a page-turning career
moment for me fantastic four rise of the
silver surfer i played the silver surfer
star trek discovery as commander
and most recently the shape of water
so when asked about how long does a
makeup take
depending on the creature it can be
anything from
a suit going on and zipping up the back
or a makeup that is applied to you from
head to toe for instance as commander
suru on star trek discovery it's around
two hours a day which is
mercifully short
flip side would be an abe sapien from
the hellboy movies so that's one of the
longer ones that took seven hours a day
wearing rubber bits it's everything that
you think it would be it is hotter than
you want it to be it is heavier than you
want it to be it is more isolating than
you want it to be you can't always make
get access to your naughty bits to go
pee if you want
why go through all of this makeup
application the time that it takes you
can create monsters with vfx now i think
people like to watch other people so
even if that person is playing a monster
they want to connect with a human's
interpretation and performance of that
monster it's old school
cinema magic
i kind of get the best of both worlds
when it comes to being a public
celebrity
the bigger movies i've been in and the
bigger things that i'm known for i look
like this
and then on the street
i'm just the tall skinny guy that's a
gift
now that i'm in in a movie like the
shape of water with 13 oscar nominations
i'm getting recognized in public a
little bit more
but it's still not to the point where i
where i have people hiding in my bushes
hoping to get a snapshot of me topless
that's not happening yet
people ask me this yeah for my day jump
isn't what you do tedious
as a stop-motion animator you're very
conscious of
time and of incrementally
moving
a three-dimensional object bit by bit by
bit
mad god is a stop-motion film that i've
been kind of making for like the last 30
years
there's nothing stopping me from
continuing doing it you know forever
[Music]
when i was five years old in 1955 i saw
king kong on television as a stupid kid
i was just enthralled by hollywood
monsters and that was really the thing
that kind of kindled my appetite
subsequently over the years i have worn
many hats in the motion picture racket
i've been involved with star wars the
robocop series
jurassic park starship troopers on and
on
one of the things that gives me a lot of
pleasure is is to make something but the
day job has certain requirements to it
over the years those requirements have
become a lot more limiting
the mad dog project allowed me to just
make this more pure thing that was kind
of a form of therapy for me as an
antidote to my day job
it's a combination of live action and
stop motion miniature sets in layers
like a collage
for lack of a better term it's a passion
project
and things keep getting
deeper and darker and hotter
there are imaginary cities that are
built out of iron ingots there's like
strange jungles that you go through
there's this
huge dystopic post-industrial
nightmare city and it just goes on and
on and on practically anything that i
can think of inherent in it there's a
level of surprise that i think you know
for me is very childlike kind of a thing
i shoot here at my studio in berkeley
it's stocked with all kinds of stuff for
all kinds of different electronic
projects woodworking projects lights
cameras so it's a huge toy box
all of the characters in that god are
built by me
the process begins with the articulated
skeleton and that's made by ball and
socket or hinge joints that allow you to
move the characters incrementally one
frame at a time
and then i just wrap lengths of
polyurethane foam and build up the
general mass
from there i will take latex skins
adhere them with rubber cement paint the
thing and it's ready to shoot
when you're actually shooting a
stop-motion scene you project into the
character and sometimes it can get very
complicated
you are always gauging acceleration and
deceleration weight and mass and then
that kind of leads to
but you know what what would make it
better
for me this whole process is more of a
compulsion
i really have no say over it's just
something that i i
i have to do
you know i've been doing it so long it's
i i breathe i live and breathe in this
world
it's
all i think about
this is hilah
he's a healer monster the only species
of lizard native to the united states
that is venomous
but don't worry these lagged lizards
aren't exactly known for their ability
to give chase
[Music]
native to the southwestern united states
and northwestern mexico the gila monster
is a hard to spot desert dweller
spending 90 of its day underground
squat and heavy set with a large tail
and head they grow to be about 20 inches
long and weigh 2 pounds their skin is
studded with dorsal scales
black in color with scattered patterns
of orange and red hues they camouflage
well amongst desert pebbles and rocks
gila monsters prey on small desert
animals and their eggs by using their
acute sense of smell
once located they bite into their prey
with their teeth and don't let go they
chew relentlessly until the venom stored
in their salivary glands can work its
way into their prey although quite toxic
their bite is not fatal to adult humans
sadly the number of gila monsters in the
wild are dropping they've lost their
habitat to housing and agricultural
development but since they spend most of
their time underground we do not know
how many are left
this is the gila monster